everybody welcome to life coding with
Jessie I'm Jessie and today we're gonna
do some CSS to our last stream which I
think was Friday Thursday or Friday of
last week we started doing some CSS work
so we're just gonna continue on with
that since the other work that I've been
doing lately is kind of boring and I'm
not really extreme worthy so I'm saving
some of the the work that might be a
little bit more interesting and easier
for beginners to follow along with so
over the weekend I had a conference
Pittsburgh tech fest and I gave a talk
there about basically a lot of stuff
we've been to one over the last few
months are using react and graph QL to
get data from WordPress so if you're
interested in that talk check it out
it's on my channel a link to my channel
is in the description and it should be
the last video that I that I did should
be right there on the the home page I
can't see the live chat right now I'm
trying to get that set up and then we'll
start
also if you do follow me on Twitter you
may have seen this message earlier if
you don't follow me on Twitter and you'd
like to link to my Twitter is in the
description as well but I have an idea
for a project that I think will be
pretty cool and I'll keep you all filled
in on on how it's going but for now I'm
just looking for advice so what I'd like
to do is use machine learning to predict
whether or not a customer will convert
whether they'll take the desired action
based on some informations they provide
in an online form so I'd like to do it
in JavaScript I've gotten I was thinking
about using brain day s I saw some
videos on it it seemed pretty easy to
work with but I've also gotten some
suggestions to use tensorflow j/s so if
anybody has any other suggestions or
advice or any good resources for me let
me know in the live chat or in the
comments or wherever you like but I
think that could be a pretty valuable
tool for for businesses I know a lot of
the bigger companies already have things
like this they either pace you know for
an outside service to do it or they do
it in-house but I'm thinking this could
be targeted more towards like smaller
businesses trying to make it you know
somewhat user friendly and you know the
the big problem is for small businesses
is just getting the amount of data
needed to really make a good prediction
with it but I do have some data that I'm
thinking of working with that I think
will be enough to get started so at
least for testing you know for us I
already have the data that I need okay
oh I forgot my my Spotify I forgot my
music the microphone finally started
working on my Mac at least I think it is
seems like y'all can hear me so now I
can listen to Spotify on my phone which
definitely helps do most other people
listen to music while you code let me
know in the chat I just always assumed
that that's like a normal thing that
people do but I've gotten so used to it
now but it's just like constant
okay
all right so I'm just taking a glance
here at the chat and then we're gonna
get started with this Matthew asks about
how about that new free code camp
content yeah I haven't I've just looked
at a little bit of it I haven't had a
chance to try any of it yet I'm thinking
about doing a series where I work my way
through the new content maybe even do it
live that would probably be on my own
channel but if anybody would be
interested in something like that let me
know and then I'll I'll think more
seriously about doing it
oh wow Michael said my last stream was
Thursday wow it's been a while sorry
about that I don't remember why I didn't
stream on Friday to be honest but
yesterday I had a doctor's appointment
that was an hour away in the morning and
the dogs appointment took longer I
thought because I had to get blood taken
and then I got back to work stopped at
the store to get something to eat for
lunch so it got to my office ate lunch
in my office and then had two meetings
back to back and then a third smaller
meeting that was no I was not expecting
and then I had to watch the kids because
my wife took my son to karate so it was
a very busy day if I would have been
able to fit a stream in it would have
been really short so as it was I ended
up getting I needed to get paperwork
done that was due by the end of the day
yesterday so anyway I don't like to have
that long of a span between streams but
it happened
oh that's it Michael thanks that's what
I remember so I did do a stream on
Friday
I just forgot about it but I did it on
my channel so that was when we got ready
for the for the talk that I did thank
you just I don't know what's up with me
just the weekend was was rough it was so
busy I needed like another weekend to
recover from my weekend all right so
let's let's get this started
seems like I've been talking too much at
the beginning here okay I'm gonna switch
scenes all right I'll make this a bit
bigger for everyone I think that's
that's probably good on sighs let me
know if it's not not sure I could go
much bigger than this and still kind of
see what's going on for for the last
hour or so I've been working on these
these routes so I've been going into
WordPress cleaning up data making sure
the slugs are correct and actually just
deleting a lot of posts that were either
not needed or I could combine with other
posts so the data came over very like
fragmented and lots of different posts
so I've been able to combine a lot and
then also add routes so I've been
running into this issue where they'll be
too and sometimes completely different
URLs for the same content so I have
Modern Languages and mod Lang lit both
go to the same content and not only that
but then on top of that so if you go
like Franciscan dot edu slash Modern
Languages slash classes it should it
takes you the same place as if you did
mod Lang lit slash classes so like this
whole tree of pages has double URLs
and I'm not sure which one is even the
the right one
I believe that depending on what link
you click on on the current site it
would take you to one or the other and
it doesn't redirect so it's a bit of a
mess but I'm glad I found that so that I
can add this in trying to avoid broken
links as much as possible all right so
that's what I've been working on so the
last few commits you'll see in the repo
are basically just that
so not really that much to catch up on
in terms of work on the github repo
anything yeah oh you can find the link
to the github repo in the description
also if anybody's been worried about
Microsoft and github or excited about it
or anything let me know in the chat that
might be cool to talk about I know
there's not a lot of details available
yet but I'm kind of should to see what
you all think I don't have any plans to
move my repos yet at least for the four
Franciscan universities repos I know you
know we use a lot of Microsoft stuff
like office 365 so I don't really see an
issue with leaving those repos on there
in terms of my personal repos I'm not
really worried about it until there some
reason to be worried about it you know
but I would like to hear what you all
think all right so I just started a
Pomodoro timer
Oh Nicky has a good point says this
Microsoft buying github mean the Adam
editor is doomed
use Visual Studio code anyway but still
that's a great point I did not even
consider that yet but yeah you know
because there let's say like I had
thought about electron because github
you know built and maintains electron
but Microsoft uses electron for for
several products and actually the
Microsoft host an electron conference I
believe or at least they sponsor it and
they contribute to the project so I
thought okay well that's actually not a
bad deal but I didn't think about Adam
whereas you know Visual Studio code is
direct competitor to Adam I would I
would hate to see Adam go away I don't
use it much anymore either but it's it's
good to have options you know
all right so this is the last page I was
working on this made this is probably a
good page for us to check out so if
you're just joining us you didn't catch
the last stream where we did CSS
basically what we're gonna do is just go
through the site and find things that
look like they need a little work so it
doesn't have to be perfect but if it
looks broken we are definitely fixing it
so I'll just scroll through this page
quickly right off the bat I see some
inconsistencies in spacing I really
don't like this long list but right now
I don't want to deal with that right now
yeah
all right there's nothing on the page
that absolutely looks broken but you
know what I do remember something I
noticed earlier so when we go to one of
these and we go to click let's say on
undergraduate we get a weird color I
don't know if you caught that on the on
the screen but it's almost like a
pinkish color so
I want to change that I want to try to
see if we could see it I'm gonna zoom in
and click to see if you all can see it
as well if you want to check out the
website you can go to dev dot Franciscan
University I'll put it in the live live
chat in just a second ok do you see that
that actually looks orange on on that
screen depending on what screen well
where did this take me I think I
accidentally clicked on something all
right so let me do all right so if you
go to the link that I just put in the
live chat you can browse through the
site as well so I believe that we change
this at one point and I don't know if it
reverted back or because we added some
of these extra dropdowns if that had
anything to do with it but oh let's take
that page that's not work good to know I
have a list of all the pages that don't
work so I'm not I'm not worried about
you know taking note of that right now
Ali Ali a fanboy says Ajax with a heart
yes
at my age act Yolo shirt it's you only
load once yeah so this is actually an
event bright shirt so I got this at the
first syntax con from Ben a leg Badu who
who works at Eventbrite does a lot of
conference talks if you don't follow Ben
on Twitter you should East a nice guy
he's got a lot of good info I think his
Twitter handle is Ben and VP alright so
let's go into code and let's
let's check out our theme and see if we
can just fix it here let's see so I
doubt it's a problem with our theme
because it looks like the style works
like if you could see that on other
click events we do have proper colors so
yeah maybe we'll have to go right into
the component actually you know where we
should go let's go to the documentation
that might save us a lot of a lot of
searching there we go
let's look I don't remember what that's
called Oh Nicky says he says I know how
to fix that give me a sec to look it up
okay cool
all right I'll give Nikki a second to
let us know about that
Aly also asks where are you from
right now I'm streaming from Ohio from
Studio hyoh
which is right on the eastern border so
right next to where Pennsylvania and
West Virginia meet so I'm pretty close
to Pittsburgh originally I am from West
Virginia and those are all of course in
the United States
okay let's see what this is I had a few
people coming in saying hello hey
everybody thanks for watching
i suture
all right so the side list we need to
check the list components then
as I believe what we've done is just
we've nested lists
oh if we actually if we just nested list
we may may be able to see this easily
okay so let's check our tour item the
jeaious
okay so this is our hover color
okay Nikki saying find the CSS for that
link and apply color inherits to it okay
let's see we're back up and go to drawer
see what we've done here
interesting let's get back in here
sub-item iconic container
it's alright I don't actually see
anything that would make the top links
change Michael asked which page you
working on I couldn't see when you
started okay this I'm not really on any
page I'm just looking at this side side
navigation all right Sonique Issa see
the external link CSS class there okay
was it on the bat on this other one oh
there we go external link color inherit
that's the same thing okay all right
cool thank you thank you Nikki
okay I see because we manually put in
those external links down here didn't we
yeah we did okay so we put that class
right on the a tag all right
that's that's super helpful all right so
let's check our a tags here and see what
classes so we do have a classes sub link
on our a tags and
I believe those are the only a tags we
have there's double-checking okay so in
our sub link let's try to put that in
there and let's save that and then we'll
try it out
great and then let's try a sub link
awesome let's make sure just shot a
couple more yeah awesome great job Nikki
that's really cool though that was a
very easy fix very easy fix so wonderful
at one time we we actually had a issue
open for that so let's check the issue
and see if it's still open we can close
it and I'm gonna check on my timer
alright so in about 11 minutes I'm gonna
come back to the chat and answer a few
questions for a little while so let's
see here we are
if she oh wow I didn't realize three
pool requests if you've submitted a pool
craft recently sorry that I haven't
checked them and pulled it and merged
them yet I'll I'll try to get that done
after the stream all right so I got a
pull request about this I'm excited to
review that faculty titles not
displaying oh I you know what I figured
out how to fix that bug because I was
having the same bug bug on my
presentation slides so I stayed up
really late on Friday and figured it out
so this might be a good one to to fix
soon before I forget how I did
all right cool so we don't have an issue
for that anymore like I said I think
someone may I think it may even have
been Nikki actually fixed that at first
but then I broke it again once I added
in that other stuff and then carry over
the styles so we can go ahead and commit
this change so we are using it as our
version control for this project so we
can check get status here in our
terminal that's integrated right in here
with visual studio code and we can see
that we have made a change to that droid
MJS and we can do a git add write to get
that file ready and then we're gonna do
your in cm because we have a little
custom script setup to help us make
well-formatted commit messages so it's a
shoot oh well I guess it's not really a
new feature it's a color change so I
don't know if you want to say that's a
feature or not so change on on click
color of course sub-items
alright yeah I guess feature is an OK
thing to do I mean it wasn't exactly a
bug or anything
Oh Michael said I've almost figured out
the first issue but I'm not quite there
yet
my regex food is terrible yeah I thought
let's let's check that out for just a
second here that pool request because I
thought one of these was about that
alright let's let's check the file let's
see what's going on alright so we now
have okay cool so we have this regular
expression here and then we're replacing
all that with this interesting
that's really the ended I mean this this
regular expression is definitely beyond
what I've ever done so that's really
awesome yet so I'm gonna have to test
that out it looks like there's a little
way to test it here I know this is a
little off topic of this today stream
but since since we were talking about it
figured why not just test it out and we
had to wait a second for this to go
through anyway alright so that worked it
passed all the tests and so let's push
that up to github
all right cool so it did match that
okay interesting so well here's here's
what I guess I'm assuming is is
happening this here this a dollar sign
three must I guess that's putting in a
third capture group so with one two
three the third capture group is well it
grabs the the URL for this link so by by
using this we're actually able to insert
like a variable whatever is captured in
there and remember that was the issue
that this was the issue that caused me
to give up on using a regular expression
because I had no idea how to do it but I
did know how to do it in JavaScript so
but this this is definitely the better
solution so we'll probably go with that
I'm not gonna merge this now it's it's
off topic what we're doing right now but
then also any like stuff I do on the
command line goes really slow what I'm
trying to stream so let's go back to our
our CSS so we've accomplished that and
I'm gonna refresh because for some
reason it's not it's not closing the
drawer when I click
okay Michael Creole says I thought we
were only trying to replace the in-text
yes yeah that's what we were trying to
do but I guess in a sense that's exactly
what's happening again but it's it's the
end result is the same if the end result
is that all the markup stays the same
except the intertext but the process to
go about that is is a little bit
different with that regular expression
so I said I I don't know that I would
have come up with that but I like it
which I mean I'm assuming that it all
works it seems like it will so I'll just
off to test it and then if everything
does work
I will merge that pull request later on
all right so what we already checked
this page let's go through I want to try
to find some pages that we haven't
really seen before Nikki said out of the
title prop two or is that already there
accessibility for the one I don't
remember if that was there or not but it
should be there if it wasn't all right
let me check I think we already checked
this some of these pages so I'm not
gonna do this top two all right we have
nothing there right now I have to build
that out employment and HR okay that's
good yeah I kind of I think we I think
we've looked at this stuff already
faculty openings I don't think this page
works no it doesn't
it's consumer information all right now
bad yeah this page didn't turn out too
bad at all
let's see if any of these pages work so
I'm just gonna open a bunch in some new
windows assuming that their interior
pages
all right no that does not work whoa
all right well it's not the worst thing
ever but I the way these are like this I
guess is centered and this one is I
wonder if these are just set to be like
right on the end of this line of both
these lines no no we may be able to work
on these but my timer just went off so
let's take a five-minute break and do
some question-and-answer I'm gonna
scroll all the way to the top see if
there's any questions if you have any
questions that you'd like for me to
answer please put them in the chat now
Nietzsche says writing a blog post about
using keyboard shortcuts to get things
in code done faster what are your
favorites interesting if anybody has any
favorite keyboard shortcuts to get
things done
let let Nikki know in the chat something
what it's kind of hard to think about
you know because you get used to them
it's kind of a thing like you just do it
you don't at some point you stop
thinking about it as some trick you know
I don't know probably the thing I use
the most that saves me time is multiple
cursors so on a Mac with Visual Studio
code it's command D now I have the atom
keyboard shortcuts enabled since I was
used to using atom so I don't know what
it is on Visual Studio code by default
but you know command e to do the
multiple cursor thing is really helpful
and I don't know I mean aside from that
all the normal ones right you know
control f4 for finding things I probably
use that oh that might be would I use
the most
also of course copy and paste but
everybody knows those ones yeah if I
think any other ones I'll let you know
oh wow Nikki does not listen to music
while coding interesting
Michael says I heard that gitlab had a
spike in activity in the last two days
not sure if it was real yeah I don't
know I mean even before the announcement
was like official you had people talking
about going to to get lab I mean I I
don't know it reminds me a little bit
it's definitely not the same situation
but it reminds me a little bit of when
everybody said they're gonna leave
Facebook you know a month or two ago and
like I didn't leave Facebook and
obviously like a lot of people just
didn't leave Facebook but in in terms of
like in terms of the people on Twitter
that I follow and on Instagram you know
there were some there was some like
reaction strong reactions to it like I
just deleted it you know I think this is
gonna end up being a similar thing like
there gonna be some really vocal people
who are like I'm definitely moving but
you're gonna see like the vast majority
of people probably end up staying with
github if not for any other reason than
just it takes a lot more effort to move
than the standstill right like there has
to be a really good reason for people to
move and I don't think they're I mean
Microsoft hasn't done anything yet
they're no decisions have been made
there's so we just don't know what's
going to happen if something drastic
changes with github
yeah then people more people might move
but if it stays largely the same just
the fact that Microsoft owns it I don't
think is gonna be enough for anybody to
move especially with I mean how many
developers use Visual Studio code now
right it's you know there are open
source Microsoft tools that are widely
accepted by developers you know why
couldn't get hub be that - right I don't
know so I think it could be awesome
it could be like heyget hubs the same
except better because now there are more
resources behind it and that would be
great
or you know it could end up being bad it
just depends on what's decided upon so
it seems like at least for now at least
till the end of the year things aren't
going to change that much so I think
they're gonna take it'll kind of slow in
the transition at least that's what I
read so that's my opinion on it which
what do I know so just take that for
what it is
- Tommy wah says I think they should
just keep both running on separate teams
I think that's where we were talking
about Visual Studio code and Adam I
think that's a good idea at least at
first keep them both running on separate
teams and you know just kind of see
where it goes from there you know if I
mean they're very similar applications
they both run on electron they both do
the same thing so I guess long term if
it ends up being that the best of one
just gets absorbed into the other that
would make sense I don't know if it
would be a good thing or but it would
make sense if it if it happens
all right so my five-minute timer is up
I'm gonna reset my Pomodoro timer after
this 25-minute session is over I'm gonna
come back to the chat and answer
whatever questions are still remaining
all right so for this page actually like
really hate to work on this page because
it's it's a standalone page styles' I do
for this aren't going to carry over into
anything else so it's like we don't get
that much for the amount of work that
we're gonna put into this so I think
we're not gonna do it this is a page
that we have to have for for our
accreditation or membership in these
organizations so we have to display this
somewhere but nobody looks at this
except for possibly the people that
police organizations to make sure that
they're displaying these things I'm not
I'm not really a fan of these things
they actually cost a lot of money just
to be able to display this and so I
don't know I've argued in the past
that's prospective students high school
students don't care at all about these
things and so it's a waste to have them
but that's not what what people think so
what other people think at my
organization so we're still gonna
continue to pay a lot of money for these
and display them for the time being but
my advice to just hide them somewhere
was taken
mainly because those those little things
that show up in there they load so many
scripts those aren't just images so many
scripts get loaded it was slowing down
we had him on the main page and was
slowing it down significantly and it's
already slow so at least at least my
idea to take him off the front page was
accepted
all right so this actually this is
really interesting I'm just looking at
the URL path to these as you know we set
up a Google Cloud Storage bucket to
store all kind of the images and the
PDFs that are on the current site and I
don't believe that I got that file
because I didn't think there is anything
live on the site that was using this
file this was this folder was supposed
to be for the admin panel of the old CMS
so evidently some files got in there
that's a really weird path
you know what I don't I don't know if
y'all can see this or not but I don't
think that's an actual path
all right I'm gonna I'm not gonna worry
about that right now but that could be
kind of a big issue if all the PDFs if
if we're not given the real path and
instead we're given the path to a dot
aspx file that then pulls in that data
given an ID that's gonna be a problem
Oh
same thing here yeah this is that's not
good
okay well at least I mean these pages in
terms of how they look are acceptable
yeah but the URLs are for these PDFs or
not the only thing I see that's really
weird here is the spacing and I'm not
sure why let's just check the code out
for a second and why are the breaks
between all of these that's insane
okay all right so it looks like whenever
this came over Wow
I'm sorry this is too small for y'all to
see let me make this bigger so you can
see what I'm looking at and just how
insane this is um this is how the
content came over when we pulled the
content over from the main site with all
these breaks in between that's that's
just all right so evidently yeah we have
so we have already had these breaks set
to display:none which is good but yeah
I'm gonna leave this like this for now
because once again this is one of those
one-off pages that nobody really looks
at anyway but we just have to have same
way with this page you know it's all
just legal stuff
wow that's really small man I guess oh
goodness
yeah these are PDFs also I'm assuming
they're PDFs I can't even tell really
but they they don't have real URLs
either okay pages all right and so all
those pages were okay I'm glad I looked
at them though because now I realize the
issues that we have with with those URLs
all right so let's check out the next I
really thought there would be more
issues with styling to be honest I think
we've gotten pretty lucky with some of
these pages let's check out this
directions and attractions combinations
that's an external link and so is that
oops
oh cool actually that's not bad even you
know the way the image is set up now I
definitely want to check this out though
on a smaller screen really it's what I
should be looking at first okay that's
not bad I was just I was worried that it
would be aligned to the right instead of
left but this I think maybe taking
advantage of some of the styles that we
created last week on a double check yep
yeah those are styles from before which
is great so these styles are being
applied elsewhere and they're doing what
they're supposed to be doing cool and
okay this is not too bad I'm not not a
fan of all this italics but like I said
we are we're looking for things that
absolutely look broken
oops
let's try this page
Wow okay we are gonna work on this page
because this page is going to be
important to the president of the
University and some of the people that
are higher up because they're really
focusing on these things they call the
the charisms of the university so we're
gonna work on this page even though it's
you know it's basically one of those
one-off pages that doesn't really get
very much traffic but in this case the
traffic that these pages do get is
important all right so we can see we
have h5 and h6 is that h1 looks okay the
h2 the size is okay but we'll see we may
have to adjust the h1 and h2 depending
on how big we go with our H fives and
sixes so let's let's work with this h5
first and let's go let's go to the font
size
let's try 18 just to start Oh actually I
think 18 looks okay and then font weight
of 300 is gonna be thin let's try 4 see
what it looks like for ya I think four
is it more acceptable yeah
4 makes a lot of sense right there
okay
alright let's figure out what's
stylesheet we should use so what's this
being used for departments so for some
reason the department stylesheet is
being applied here I get that the page
is being applied here that's weird
alright let's check let's check this out
so we have about visions of charism
let's go to the drawer menu Jas and this
should tell us what we're using to
render this page you want another one of
those where'd you get that one yeah I
have another one come here you won't be
on YouTube good the other my oldest son
is is here he's asking me for some of
the stuff the the conference swag that I
got you know what I think I have it down
here I'll give it to you give it to you
a little bit here say hi you're right
there down in the corner there
this is Raphael that's my oldest you
wanna say anything to people and you do
you don't know you wanna hang out for a
little bit okay
so Raphael here's what we're trying to
do you see how on this page watch that
cup there's stuff in it you see oh these
are really small so we're trying to
change that so they're not really small
so right now we figured out some code to
use to change it but we just need to
figure out the right place to put it so
we're gonna look here and what was the
title of that page it's a vision Cara
Sonos so actually we can just do a
control fine the vision and Cara's on
this
age type about pages about pages alright
let me check our server
see
I know I need to check I should have a
route that is just for about and then we
can see what it's what component is
automatically being rendered all right
let me just scroll up cuz I think it's
at the top
maybe I don't have it
at the bottom here all right let's
yeah it should be rendering to page all
right well let's just look at page I
mean it's possible that I've I've loaded
that CSS and page I dude so for some
reason in the page a s component I'm
loading the department CSS stylesheet as
well I don't remember why I'm doing that
so I'm gonna leave it there for now but
maybe I'll go back and look at the get
get history for this component and see
when I did that and maybe you know maybe
then I'll remember why it's there if
it's a mistake I'll take it out but for
now let's put these styles in the page
dot CSS so we need to find our static
folder let's close up some of these
there are static
styles and then let's find that page dot
CSS we think I thought we think about
this work it's a lot yeah the people in
this dream helped too all right so I'm
just gonna put it down here at the
bottom and we're gonna say h5 and I
really hope that I copied those styles
no I didn't okay I think it's easy to
remember though I believe we went with a
font size font size of 18 pixels and a
font weight
rates of 400 all right so let's save
that and do a refresh see if it works
yeah it worked
okay cool now let's look at these eight
sixes these are really tiny and let's
see what we can do so font size I'm
gonna go start at 18 pixels and see how
that looks actually that's that's not
too bad but only because it has that
bold you know font weight let's see if
we drop it down to like 400 if it's
still gonna look like
actually it's that's not bad
let me let me bump it up I'm trying to
avoid making them so big that I have to
adjust these larger headings but if we
can go to 20 actually I like that and
then I want to see where all this
padding is okay wow that's a lot of
padding we definitely are I'm sorry
margin we don't need that much margin so
I'm gonna leave the margin top for now
and let's just go with margin bottom
whoops margin bottom let's let's try
eight pixels oh yeah that's a lot better
yeah that's so much better
we're gonna go with eight I think I
could go even further because it looks
like I think there's some margin there
on those Peas yeah so let's go down
further
and we go down there that well one okay
we probably can just go to zero then
margin bottom zero yeah I'm gonna go
margin bottom zero since we have such a
large margin that seems to be by
defaults here yeah just in the
user-agent so yeah I'm gonna set a
margin bottom zero on those I'm a little
bit afraid that these styles are gonna
mess things up on other pages though so
we're gonna have to make sure as we
click around that we we check but you
know they definitely need to be bigger
no matter what page they're on that font
size was just unacceptable so I think
this will be I think this will be okay
that I mean that looks a lot better okay
so let's move these over here it's
throwing our h6 and then put the styles
and clean up I need to get a plug-in or
something that auto formats my CSS since
that would be nice
alright so that's in there let's do a
refresh just to make sure
yep
great okay
Jeff malicious doesn't prettier do CSS
yeah actually we are using prettier
probably just need to set that up then
nikki says shouldn't h6 be smaller than
h5 you are correct you're entirely
correct and normally I would say yeah
we're gonna do that for sure but in this
case the mark that were given doesn't
make sense
so like this is not really a heading
this is I don't even know like maybe I
would make this a blockquote
or something if I was gonna do it yeah
so this should not be an H 5 it's it's
not a heading
these are headings for each one of these
little sections so they're actually
better yet if they're gonna list
charisms
this is should be like dictionary style
lists I forget what the HTML tags are so
anyway there are better ways that would
make more sense to set up this HTML so I
entirely agree that the h6 should
normally be smaller than an h5 but we're
just doing what we have to do to make
this look okay with the mark-up of given
and then we're going to go back like
over the course of the next year I or
someone else I can hire is going to go
in here and make sense of all this
markup and we won't have silly things
like that happening you know eventually
and actually since this is kind of like
a one-off page we maybe could have gone
in and actually adjusted this but I
don't want to get into a habit of doing
that because then the site will never
launch okay
I'm gonna check my timer oh we only have
about a minute left so I'm just gonna
commit this change and then I'll I'll
answer some questions and then we'll
we'll wrap up the string I still get
status
there we go that's that's what we want
to see just that CSS files changed and
we'll do a git add yarn cm and let's I
guess we can do a fix for this that was
obviously I guess a UI bug right a
design bug I don't know so let's say fix
any sizes and weights
okay so that's gonna do its thing and I
can start answering questions now as
soon as that's done I'll just I'll push
it up to the repo and and then that way
everything will be available to you all
John Hanson says you need to need a
Visual Studio code extension for color
highlight yeah you know what I had that
on Adam and it was pretty awesome that
would be cool to have one on there just
in your code but I'm kind of like I'm
trying to not have extensions that I
don't need running because it does tend
to slow things down and since I already
have issues with trying to stream on on
this laptop I probably won't do it here
I have no problems adding in more stuff
on my my iMac at work though because it
can handle it coding in caffeine says hi
developers and coffee drinkers yeah I
have my iced espresso here so I'm with
you today um Rahul says when will this
project be over I really hope we get
this thing launched before July it based
on my initial plans it would have been
launched already something's happened
we're support I was surprised by the
quality and amount of data to be honest
with you and then I also had expected to
be able to hire on some student workers
and that just didn't happen so so it got
extended out I mean if it ultimately
helps you know make this a better you
know a better project a more smooth
launch I guess it's okay but I I really
I don't arted to get nervous when the
project drags on you know I just wanted
to launch I get what happens it's like
the longer you wait to develop a project
it just makes me nervous become because
it'll start to become outdated before it
even launches right you don't want it to
get so old that you have to at some
point go back and completely redo the
projects but it but you don't want to
launch something outdated so it's almost
like you'd have to at some point also
the project goes on and on people keep
coming up with you know new
ideas for things to do I don't like that
I'd rather launch it and then any
changes are gonna be based on user
feedback and analytics data and not just
on well what if we did this or that all
right so I'm pushing that up to github
that will be ready in just a second
coding and caffeine says love material
by the way thank you
Nietzsche says all that PR for pretty
early eslint you can postpone we're just
trying that out on a different project
than the one I used as a sample for a
blog post oh okay all right thanks
John Hanson says don't know if it would
be a small change to give hover to your
anchor tag to darker color oh you know
what I were talking about that last week
warrant Li yeah I don't think it would
be too difficult of a thing to change so
that might be something that we do at
some point I think it would be good the
world's asks how do you get react in a
production mode yeah so it depends on
what you use to to to build it with so
we use next so if we check out the
package.json it will it'll tell
basically we we just run this command
and it does all the transpiling and
minifying concatenated everything so we
just type in build right I think if it's
if you use create react app it's also
build so of course it'd be yarn build or
NPM run build or something like that if
you set it up from scratch then I guess
you'd make the build command whatever
you wanted it to be
I'm Michael Crowes that I had to do
something and then I see Jesse's mini-me
on the stream yeah yeah he's off of
school now so what is your first week
off of school right yeah
what do you been doing now that you
don't have school not coding right now
anyway there we go you playing outside
and stuff that's good
go rob GA you are a V I'm sorry if I'm
messing up your name please let me know
how to pronounce it if I am anyway says
looks clean isn't it so I guess you're
saying the site looks clean
if so thank you that's definitely what I
was going for as a clean interface Oh
John Hanson said Nikki's blog is is
helpful Nikki I'm gonna check that out
for sure I'm pretty sure you gave me the
link to that before if you didn't give
it to me and if you did is it cool if
you give it to me again
I'm gonna check the my Twitter DM z--
after this to see if you gave me the
link already in Twitter or I'll just
check your Twitter profile how about
that and it's I you probably have it
linked from there so don't worry about
it yeah but I definitely want to check
it out the Jeff Miller says Jessie I owe
you a docker compose file for local
minecraft server oh yeah yeah I mean
don't don't worry about it I mean I
don't I don't want you to you know take
a bunch of time out of your schedule to
do that but if you get a chance that
would be really cool you know that he's
remember I told you someone from the
livestream was gonna help and give us a
file which so we can create a minecraft
server maybe so we'll create it and
it'll run on like one of these computers
so like we'll just at home we'll be able
to play it yes it'll just be for us so
then you don't have to worry about
anything like any bad guys on the
internet or anything yeah it'll be cool
we could we can build awesome things huh
all right okay Nikki's blog is Nikki I
pronounce your last name uh-huh let me
let me spell it out anyway because if if
you can see the string now obviously you
can copy and paste that if you're
listening before I need you spell it
anyway
it's ni c KY m e UL e ma n dot net liffe
i.com slash blog yes so I'm gonna copy
and paste that into my browser right now
so I don't forget
okay michael says since all the
questions on your stream talks were
about graph QL if you get good at
explaining it you'd have an itch you
could dominate yeah I guess so
I did get talks about graph QL I think I
am I think I could have done better talk
if I would have if I would have
explained more about reacting graph to L
and how they work at first because it
seemed like the people in the audience
some of them I had never even used react
before and a lot of them had never used
graph QL before so so the kind of the
rest of the talk was a little hard to
follow because I had assumed in order to
get through all of the material on time
I had to assume that the audience would
have already set up certain things on
their own so I don't maybe I could have
kind of front-loaded to talk a little
bit more with some explanation so I mean
really that I actually have taken that
same content and I want to present it as
a like a three to five hour workshop and
really go through and actually build out
a whole like demo project with everyone
so that that I think would really be a
better a better fit but still at least I
think the audience members got ideas for
what's possible so they'll definitely
have to learn more about reacting graph
to L if they want to do it on their own
but but perhaps now they may see that
something is possible and not that
difficult to do that maybe they didn't
even realize what was the thing before
and that's I think that's valuable
okay Jeff says for what it's worth I
used this docker image and has linked up
okay cool I'll have to look up that
docker image so actually I have docker
sorry I'm probably gonna run this on one
of my Windows machines I think I have
darker running on one of them are
installed but it's been quite a long
time since I've developed anything so I
could probably do some updates but I
could probably test it on this Mac
though alright well I've gotten to the
end of the live chat and I think this
was a full stream just you know basic
CSS stuff but it's always fun good job
on all the code everybody I'm gonna try
to be back tomorrow
[Music]